[Musique]
je me suis dit base y aller ce serait
trop simple de rien faire et puis et
puis ça m'a donné aussi envie de faire
un disque très collaboratif
[Musique]
il arrivait avec une guitare si bien
fumer une clope et brunes guerre j'en
suis là budget pour la santé
et il arrive et me dit regarde j'ai fait
ça et en fait on avait un peu arrêter le
groupe brut où ils montrent ils
commencent un truc je dis assez marrant
jusque j'irai pas chercher ma basse du
jarret
et rémy qui arrive et il prend
un petit truc à auzits bat l'ès contes
monfreid par un groupe
[Musique]
j'ai connu l'époque nous on avait la
croix nous donner la croix d'honneur
quand on avait bien travaillé donc
c'est quelque part un peu cet enfant là
qui au fond de moi ça me fait plaisir
[Musique]